[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تعهد المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا
برناردينو ليون بمواصله الحوار الليبي حتى
نجاحه رغم وجود اعداء السلام الذين يشجعون
الحل العسكري في ليبيا على حد قوله من
جانب اخر وزير والشؤون الخارجيه التونسي
الطيب البكوش قال ان بلاده تجري اتصالات
مع اطراف الازمه الليبيه لدعم الحوار
بينها نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما هي الجهات التي عناها ليون في
تلميحه الى وجود مستفيدين من تعطيل الحوار
الليبي والى اي حد يعكس الموقف التونسي
مواقف الجوار الليبي القريب من الحوار
سيما الموقفين المصري وال
الجزائريه في تلميح كاد يلامس التصريح
اعرب مبعوث الامم المتحده الى ليبيا
برناردينو ليون عن استيائه من محاولات بعض
الاطراف عرقله الحوار الليبي الذي ترعاه
الامم المتحده وتدور جلساته في مدينه
السخيرات المغربيه وفي ظل الحديث عن
التشابك الشديد بين الداخل الليبي
والتاثيرات الاقليميه المباشره عليه فان
وصف ليون اطرا بعينها بانها عدو للسلام
تمقت الحل السياسي وتدفع باتجاه الحل
العسكري يحيل ايضا الى التساؤل عن مواقف
دول محيط ليبيا عن التطورات التي تشهدها
ازمتها وطبيعه المحاولات المبذوله
لحلها كلما احرزت مفاوضات الاطراف الليبيه
في المغرب تقدما ازدادت مخاوف رئيس بعثه
الامم المتحده الى ليبيا برنان دينو
ليون خوف بدا هذه المره اوضح لدى الرجل
وهو يتحدث في ختام الجوله الرابعه للحوار
الليبي قائلا ان اعداء السلام سيرفعون من
وتيره عملهم خلال الفتره القادمه لم
يحددهم بالاسم لكن في النزاعات عموما ثمه
دائما من لا مصلحه له في اي حل سلمي
ولربما كان الصراع والفوضى مسوغ وجوده
الوحيد ولعل ما يؤكد ذلك ويبرر بالتالي
مخاوف ليون هو ان اتفاق المتحاورين في
المغرب على وثيقه سياسيه مشتركه انجز نحو
80% من موادها تزامن مع تصعيد غير مسبوق
على الارض في ليبيا فقد اندلعت مواجهات
طاحنه خلال اليومين الماضيين في انحاء من
العاصمه طرابلس شملت منطقتي تاجورا وفشل
بين قوات فجر ليبيا وقوات اللواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر وقد خلفت تلك المعارك مقتل
واصابه العشرات لا سما من قوات حفتر
وقوبلت بتنديد ليون وحيث ان طرفي الازمه
الاساسيين وهما المؤتمر الوطني العام
وبرلمان البرق المنحل حاضران في الحوار
وقد لا يكون من مصلحه اي منهما تقويض
المحادثات تتجه الانظار الى اللواء حفتر
فهو لا مكان واضحه له في الحوار وقد لا
يكون معنيا باي اهداف سياسيه لا ينجزها
قتال او انقلاب كما حاول ذلك مرارا ومما
يدعم ذلك ان علاقته ببرلمان طبرق المنحل
وحكومته هي علاقه تقاطع موضوعي املتها
المرحله خلافا لما عليه الحال لقوات فجر
ليبيا وتشكيلاتها المختلفه التي هي اقرب
الى الذراع العسكريه للمؤتمر الوطني العام
وهيئه الاركان منذ نشاتها واذ قلل المبعوث
الدولي من امكانيه نجاح محاولات تقويض
الحوار يبقى ان اقتراب مفاوضات المغرب من
انجاز اختراق نوعي في جدار الازمه الليبيه
مرهون ايضا بمعده دول الجوار وهو موقف
ايجابي عموما ان لجهه الجزائر التي
استضافت جولات حوار او حتى تونس التي اكد
وزير خارجيتها اجراءها عده اتصالات باطراف
الازمه من اجل تسويتها وحده النظام المصري
الذي سبق وان حاول دون جدوى حشد الدعم
الدولي لتدخل عسكري في ليبيا لا يبدو
اليوم متحمسا للحوار الليبي الليبي وان لم
يعلن
ذلك موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
طرابلس المحلل السياسي عصام الزبير ومن
باريس صلاح القادري الباحث السياسي
الجزائري المختص في قضايا العالم العربي
والاسلامي وبن واشنطن نبيل ميخائيل استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه جورج واشنطن
اهلا بضيوفي الكرام ابدا بضيفي من واشنطن
سيد نبيل ميخائيل لاساله عن ان كان لديه
تصور من عناهم السيد ليون عندما قال بان
هناك اطراف تعرقل الحل السياسي وتدفع
باتجاه الحل العسكري برايك من هي هذه
الاطراف ربما تكون اطراف اوروبيه ربما
تكون اطراف عربيه ممكن تكون مصر بس
المشكله ان يعني المبعوث الاممي لن يستطيع
منع حرب هو بيحاول التوفيق ما بين جماعات
صعب التوصل الى اتفاق بينهم ربما سيتوصل
الى نتيجه ان الكفه يجب ان ترجح لطرف ما
عن الاخر يعني الى اي مدى سيقيم توازن في
الحياه والسياسه والمجتمع في ليبيا هناك
اطراف اوروبيه دول جنوب البحر المتوسط من
اسبانيا مرورا بفرنسا وايطاليا وربما ربما
حتى اليونان كلهم بيشعر ان ليبيا مشكله
يعني النهارده الصحف في امريكا كلها بتقول
كارثه انسانيه قادمه من ليبيا الا وهي
غرق زوارق للاسف بتحمل مواطنين تركوا
ليبيا في ظروف سيئه يحاولوا
العبور ن عفوا لم افهم وجهه نظرك عندما
يتكلم سيد عندما يتكلم السيد ليون ان هناك
اطراف تعرقل الحل السياسي وتدفع اتجاه
وتشجع الحل العسكري كيف لدول اوروبيه ان
تفعل
ذلك لان اوروبا هي اللي اطاحت بالقذافي كل
الكلام اللي اتقال عن ان اداره اوباما
مهدت لعمليه بريطانيه فرنساويه قامت
بالاضاحي ده مش سليم زي ما ذكرت في حديث
سابق انا سمعت من ناس اتكلموا مع قاض في
حلف نيتو قال ان الاوروبيين والدول
الصغيره زي هولندا وزي الدنمارك هم اللي
قاموا بالعبء العسكري وبعدين اوباما عمل
تصرف في غايه الغباء الا وهو انه رفض ان
تكون قوات نيتو بعد الاطاحه بالقذافي قوات
حفظ سلام دي مشكله العقيده العسكريه
الامريكيه يدخلوا حرب ومش عارفين يخلصو
علشان مش عارفين فكره واحده ان القوات
المسلحه بعد القتال بتبقى
قوات صدام في 91 ذكرت مصر ماذا عن مصر
بايجاز لو
سمحت حاضر بالنسبه لمصر لو في دول اوروبيه
وبذات فرنسا وايطاليا بتحبس العمل العسكري
مصر هتيم لان مصر ترى ان ليبيا خطر على
امنها القومي وعدم استقرار ليبيا هو عدم
استقرار للامن القومي المصري فالامر مش
محتاج مجاملات او خجل لو كان المبعوث
الاممي ب مصر مصر سواء رسميا او اعلاميا
او شعبيا هتقول نعم نحن مهتمين بالشان
الليبي ونستطيع الدفاع عن حدودنا بس مصر
مش هتروح لوحها ليبيا مصر م راحتش يعني
مصر بتقيد السعوديه في اليمن لو هناك تدخل
مصري في ليبيا حيكون اوروبي حيكون عربي
هيكون شمال افريقيا طيب دعني ايضا اسال
على نفس النقطه ضيفي من باريس سيد صلاح
القادري عن منعنا السيد ليون عندما اشار
الى اطراف وقال بانها تعرقل الحل السياسي
ومجريات الحوار في السخيرات من عنا او من
يتهم برايك السيد
ليون السيد برنارديو ليون الظاهر انه وجد
نفسه امام طريق مسدود عارف جيدا ان هناك
اطراف قريبا منه يعني تجلس ممكن ليس بعيده
او على طاوله الحوار معه او اطراف متحالفه
معها او اطراف اخرى هي حقيقه لا تريد للحل
السياسي ان يكون هو الحل الامثل والافضل
والاولى للمشهد السياسي الليبي هذه
الاطراف التي نستطيع ان نجملها في في موقف
واحد او في في توجه واحد التوجه هذا هو
انها هذه الاطراف كلها تشتغل بشكل مباشر
او غير مباشر ضد ثوره الشعب الليبي التي
هي ثوره 17 فبراير هذه الاطراف
يمكني اعرني سي صلاح ايضا عفوا هذا ايضا
كلام عام نريد ان نسمي برايك من هي هذه
الاطراف بالاسماء نعم انا ساف انا سافس
تفضل نعم سافس الان انا سافس الطرف الاول
الذي هو الذي هو يعرقل الحوار هي جماعه
حفطر والاطراف والجهات والشخصيات التي
كانت جزء من النظام السابق اللي هو النظام
القذافي الطرف الثاني هي اطراف سياسيه
تعرف جيدا من الطرفين اطراف السياسيه سواء
هي الان متحالفه مع المؤتمر الوطني العام
او فجر ليبيا او مع عمليه كرامه الكرامه
او البرلمان طبرق هذه الاطراف السياسيه
تعلم جيدا انها لا تملك امتدادا شعبيا
وبالتالي اي عمليه سياسيه سلميه او اي تقد
تعمليه ديمقراطيه ستجعلهم خارج لعبه
السلطه الطرف الثالث هي الدوله الاسلاميه
الدوله الاسلاميه في الارض هي تحاول ان
تعرقل الحوار والتاريخ الدوله الاسلاميه
في المشهد السوري وفي المشهد العراقي انها
دائما كانت دائما ليست ضد النظام او ضد
الثوره المضاده ولكن كانت مع الثوره
المضاده وكانت دائما تضرب قوه الثوار
والذي جعلته ومعاركها مع الجيش السوري
الحر في المشهد السوري في الثوره السوريه
افضل مثال على ذلك النقطه الرابعه هي
الدول الاقليميه التي صنعت ومولت ودعمت
الثوره واستفادت من الثوره المضاده واقصد
هنا وافضل مثال على ذلك هي النظام السيسي
النظام السيسي في مصر النظام السيسي في
مصر هو جزء من الثوره المضاده التي قادتها
بعض الدول العربيه وبعض الدول الاقليميه
والدوليه ضد ضد ضد الدول الشعوب العربيه
التي ثارت من اجل ان ان ان ان تسترجع حقها
في السياده وتسترجع حقها في صناعه
الديمقراطيه والتنميه والحريات هذه
الاطراف الاربعه نستطيع ان نضيف
اليها طرفا طرفا خامسا هذا الطرف الخامس
هو ماذا هي بعض القوى العسكريه المنضوي
تحت فج التي هي من ضويه او قريبه من فجر
ليبيا واقصد هنا مثلا تنظيم انصار الشريعه
هذه التنظيمات العسكريه التي لا تؤمن بحل
الدوله المدنيه وتنادي بالدوله الدينيه
هذه الاطراف لا لا ليست مستفيده من اي حل
سياسي ومن اي حوار الاطراف الخمسه التي
سمتها هي الاطراف التي تع تعرقل ساعود لك
سيد صلاح ولكن دعني افصل اكثر في مساله
فيما يتعلق بالاطراف الداخليه لاسال ضيفي
من طرابلس المحلل السياسي ع ص الزبير ايضا
عن منعنا من وجه بشكل غير مباشر سيد
برناردينو ليون اتهامه بان هناك اطراف
تعرقل الحوار السياسي والحل السياسي في
ليبيا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه
والسلام على ارش المرسلين اولا حقيقه انا
اعيب على السيد برنان دينو ليون انه دائما
في بياناته تحمل الغموض كان يجب ان تكون
هذه البيانات وخاصه من منظمه هي منظمه ما
تعتبر سلطه عليا في المجتمع الدولي ان
توضح في بياناتها كل هذه الاطراف وان
تضعها امام المسؤوليه ولكن ما يعاب عنه
انها دائما تضعنا حتى في عمليه ال وصف
اطراف النزاع كذلك بهذه الشكل حتى عمليه
الادانه للتفجيرات تكون بهذا الشكل وهذا
امر خطير هو سيجر البلاد الى اشياء لا لن
تقف لان الامور لم
تحدد لم اطراف كثيره هي متعدده عصام برايك
من يعني من هي هذه الاطراف التي عناها سيد
ليون هي اطراف متعدده منها عسكريه ومنها
سياسيه هناك حتى اطراف عسكريه جرت البلاد
الى العديد من الاشكاليات والعديد
من الامور التي اصبحت
كد سيد سيد
عصام انا بدات في التفصيل الان انا بدات
في التفصيل
الانيه الكرامه
اه عمليه الكرامه بدات شهر مايو الماضي لم
يتم تحقيق اي نزاح الى الان على الارض ولم
تحقق السيطره على مدينه بنغازي حسب ما
اراد وقال اسبوعين بعدها مضت من شهور واى
الان لم يتم تحقيق انزاز على الارض كذلك
عمليه التصارع الان التي هي موجوده
للاحزاب على مستوى الدوله الليبيه وما حدث
فيها من تشتت اثناء تتوازه المؤتمر الوطني
العام حتى تم ما قلب الطاوله عليه واعتبر
انتهت مدته وذلك نتيجه تناحر الاحزاب على
ا السيطره على هذا المؤتمر وما نتج عنها
خروج حزب التحالف وبقي المؤتمر الان
بالمستقلي وبعض التيارات الاسلاميه موجوده
به هناك بعض الاطراف تعتبر فجر ليبيا
والشروق عمليات عسكريه ولكن هؤلاء يعتبرون
انفسهم انهم ضد القوه المضاده او الثوره
المضاده التي تعمل على عدم استقرار ليبيا
هذه اطراف عديده وهناك اطراف اخرى دخلت
نتيجه الصراع الان بين طرفين عسكريين
تولدت اطراف عديده هذه الاطراف وجدت الجو
الملائم لها منها اطراف ارهابيه مثل ما
يسمى بتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه ومنها اطراف
اخرى هي اطراف تسعى الى الاجرام من عناصر
الجريمه المنظمه ومنها كذلك الهجره الغير
شرعيه وتهريب البشر والتجار بهم وكذلك
تجاره المخدرات ومنها ايضا الاجندات
الاجنبيه التي تحاول بكل قوه ان
تضرب الصراع داخل ليبيا وان تجعله يتفاعل
نظرا لعدم تغلب مصلحتها على المشهد
وابرازها بصوره كبيره على الارض هذه
الاجندات خاصه التي تاتي من خارج البلاد
والتي لها تحالف كبير الان في داخل في في
تواجدها وهناك المجتمع الدولي احيانا ي
سيشارك للاجندات الخارجيه كما سميتها وزير
الخارجيه التونسي اشار الى تونس تبدل
مجهود من اجل تقريب وجهات النظر بين
الاطراف ليبيه سوف نناقش مساله تاثير دول
الجوار تحديدا الجزائر وكذلك مصر بالاضافه
الى تحركات تونسي فيما يتعلق بالدفع
باتجاه حل حله الوضع انجاح الحوار السلمي
او تعقيده من قبل هذا الطرف او ذاك بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش مستقبل الحوار الليبي في ضوء
المحاولات الداخليه والاقليميه لتعطيل
مساره سيد صلاح القاضي ضيفي من باريس
يفترض ان الحسابات الجزائريه والحسابات
المصريه اذا كان الهدف هو مواجهه من
يوصفون بالعناصر الارهابيه في ليبيا الهدف
واحد بين العاصمتين الجزائر والقاهره ولكن
نجد هناك اختلاف في تعاطي الجزائري مع
الشان الليبي والتعاطي المصري فيما يتعلق
وبالتالي بشكل او باخر ربما توجيه اصابع
الاتهام الى القاهره بانها تحاول ان تعرقل
وليس ان تنجح هذا الحوار ما تفسير هذا
التباين المشترك بين النظامين النظام وانا
اتكلم عن الانظمه لا اتكلم عن الشعوب
المشترك بين النظامين الجزائري والنظام
المصري ان في بدايه الربيع العربي ان اقصد
النظام المصري يعني الدوله العميقه التي
انقلبت على الثوره في مصر بالاضافه الى
النظام الجزائري الحالي الى النظامين كان
لهما موقف سلبي من الربيع العربي ولكن
الجزائر تعاملت باكثر براغماتيه من النظام
المصري لانها لم تمس بشكل مباشر النظام
المصري كان الحالي هو جزء من الثوره
المضاده على الربيع العربي فبالتالي موقفه
من ليبيا سيكون موقفا طبيعيا على انه موقف
عدائي للثوره لماذا لان الثوره المضاده
وحلفائها والذين صنعوها حينما اوصلوا نظام
السيسي ليحكم مصر لم يوصلوا هنالك ليتمتع
ب بحكم مصر ولكنه ليستمر في في في تيار
الثوره المضاده وكذلك يكون هو القوه
الضاربه للثوره المضاده في المشهد الليبي
بالنسبه للنظام الجزائري كان دائما يدافع
النظام الجزائري عن عدم التدخل الاجنبي
ولذلك اعتبر ان الناتو هو من اسقط
القذافي لكن النظام الجزائري يعرف جيدا
على ان ليس من مصلحته تقدم غلبه الحل
العسكري على الحل السياسي في ليبيا لان
هذا سيفتح عليه مشاكلا كثيره اول هذه
المشاكل
ان هناك ستكون مشاكل حدوديه ان ستقوم
بعمليه تصريب وعمليه تهريب للاسلحه الى
الداخل
الجزائري النقطه الاخرى على انه عدم
الاستقرار شمال افريقيا بالنسبه للنظام
الجزائري سيمثل له تهديدا سياسيا
واقتصاديا كذلك واجتماعيا ليس الاجنده
النظامين ليست نفس الاجنده اجنده نظام هو
جزء من الثوره المضاده يجب عليه ان يستكمل
وان ان يستكمل او ان يكون القوه الضاربه
للثوره المضاده في ليبيا ونظام اخر يبحث
دائما على ان عن عمليه استقرار حفظا هل هو
استقرار من اجل استقرار النظام الشعب ليبي
والدوله الليبيه ام هو استقرار البحث
براغماتي عن استقرار ليبيا من اجل ضمان
استقراره هو كنظام ناهيك عن بغض النظر عن
مصلحه الشعبين الجزائري والليبي لا نعرف
ولكن هناك اجنت مختلفتان وان كان الدافع
لذلك ليس دائما البحث عن مصلحه الشعب
الليبي سيد نبيل ميخائيل مرت شهور طويله
على ما قيل بانها حسابات مصريه في ليبيا
عندما دعمت فريق على حساب فريق وهذه
الحسابات لم تؤتي اكلها الى الان لماذا
مازال اتهام موجه الى القاهره بانها ترجح
وتدعم الحل العسكري وليس الحل السياسي في
ليبيا لحسم القضيه المبعوث الاممي بيقول
ان 80% من الاتفاق جاهز بس لو تم استكمال
الاتفاق هل سيؤدي هذا الى تحقيق توازن في
الحياه في ليبيا انهاء الحرب الاهليه
الاستقرار في اطراف عديده جدا مصر ضمنها
عدد من الدول الاوروبيه بتشكك في فعاليه
وجدوى المبعوث الدولي لان حلوله قد لا
تؤدي الى استقرار في ليبيا قد تؤدي الى
حرب بارده ما بين الاطراف الليبيه
المتسارعه انا بتكلم هنا من واشنطن
الصحه تربط بين في ليبيا انت تربط بين
الحسابات المصريه وبين حسابات بعض الدول
الاوروبيه ولا اجد رابط بين ال بين اثنين
بين القاهره وبين بعض العواصم ان كان هذا
صحيحا فيما يتعلق بالشان الليبي الحسابات
المصريه حسابات منفصله لما يجري في
ليبيا لا هتبقى في استراتيجيه دوليه تجاه
ليبيا اولها استبعاد دور امريكا امريكا مش
عارفه تتعامل مع الموقف في اليمن امريكا
مش عارفه تتعامل في المواقف مع سوريا
امريكا مش عارفه تتعامل في الموقف مع
ليبيا زي ما ذكرت الصحف النهارده في
امريكا بتقول لنا كارثه انسانيه وبتقول
تقول ان ايطاليا بتعلن حاله الطوارئ بسبب
غرق المهاجرين القادمين على متن سفن
وزوارق الى الى شواطئ الايطاليه قادمين من
ليبيا معنى كده انها بقت مشكله اوروبيه
ايطاليه اسبانيه يونانيه وغيرها مصر ايضا
بترى ان الموقف غير المستقر في ليبيا
بيهدد حدودها فهناك رؤيه
مستقره مشارك سؤال سؤالي سؤالي واضح مبني
على ما قاله المبعوث الدولي واتهامه
لاطراف بانها تعرقل الحل السياسي وليس على
ما هو ناشئ فيما يتعلق بموضوع المهاجرين
غير
الشرعيين ايوه ما هو الاطراف دي ما لو كان
في حل سياسي ما كانش المهاجرين هيغرقوا ما
كانوش هيهربوا اصلا ما كانوش حفروا ا
طالبين الملاز باي طريقه هناك دول مجاوره
لليبيا سواء في الشمال الافريقي بما فيها
جمهوريه مصر العربيه ودول في جنوب البحر
المتوسط ترى ان الموقف في ليبيا غير مستقر
ومهام المبعوث الدولي لن تؤدي الى اي
نتيجه على الاقل انهاء الصراع المسلح
فالامر ده كله بيتم في نفس الوقت ان
امريكا مستبعده فبالتالي هيكون هناك
مشاركه ما بين المواقف المصريه والمواقف
الاوروبيه اكد لك كده لان امريكا مش مهتمه
ب مصر هتسال دول زي ايطاليا انتم في
الداخل في ليبيا كيف ترون وتقيم دور دول
الاقليم دول الجوار تحديدا الجزائر تونس
وكذلك مصر ومن له القدره ان يكون وسيط او
فاعل بشكل ايجابي من اجل دعم الحل السياسي
في
ليبيا اولا لابد ان نحدد ان هذه الدول
التي توجد في المغرب العربي كلها تتجه نحو
الحل السلمي وكلها تسعى بمساعي ما يسعى
اليه السيد اليون ولكن ما وجد في شرق
ليبيا حقيقه في شرق البلاد يعني من مصر
الى الاردن الى الامارات كلها تسعى الى
الحل العسكري من اجل تحقيق نصر حتى تتغلب
ال الطرف الذي هي تؤيده وما استقبالها
للسي للفريق الاول حفتر والى بعض
العسكريين وبرام الاتفاقيات في مصر الا
دليل على ذلك انه ليس اتجاه نحو الحل
السياسي بل اتجاه نحو الحل العسكري وهو من
صعد الامر بل ان مصر
ص بعثت لليبيا برسائل عديده منها حولت حتى
الصراع بين اسلامي وغير اسلامي
كصراع اسلامي ليبرالي رغم ان الليبيين
كلهم مجتمع اسلامي معتدل حتى المتطرفين لا
يمثلون نسبه كبيره بالنسبه بسيطه منهم في
محاوله منها تصدير موقفها ضد الاخوان
وتصديره الى المشهد الليبي وهو ما نعاني
منه الان نتيجه لعدم الثقافه السياسيه في
المجتمع الليبي ونتيجه عدم التمييز بين
التيارات الاسلاميه وهو الذي يزيد من
تصعيد الموقف الموقف المصري مؤثر جدا
وخاصه بالتحام بالمشهد الذي يوجد في في
شرق البلاد ودفعه
بقوه وبتهرش
اللهحلقات احده لديها معلومات في نهايه
العام الماضي بدخول اسلحه الى ليبيا و
عندما دخلوا الى مدينه التاجان لبعض
المعسكرات وجدوا سلاح جديد وصل الى البلاد
وقيل بانه وصل عن طريق مصر هذه الامور لا
تساعد على الحوار بل هي تعمل على زعزعه
الحوار واتجاه نحو عسكره الحوار هم الى
الان لم يعرفوا ما الذي سيكون على راس هذه
الدوله ولذلك يعملون على تجيج الحوار الى
حين ان يصنعوا شخصا يكون لهم هو الذي يكون
لهم رئيسا لليبيا كي يتمكنوا من تغليب
مصالحهم وقضاء على مصالح الشعب الليبي
لانهم يعلمون ان ليبيا دوله محوريه اساسيه
في شمال افريقيا وفي المغرب العربي وفي
مقابلتها للدول اوروبا طيب سيد صلاح
القادري باعتقادك ايا كانت الاطراف التي
تدفع باتجاه ترجيح كفه العسكري سواء كانت
اطراف داخليه او خارجيه او اطراف داخليه
يتم تحريكها من الخارج الى اي مدى لها
القدره فعلا ان تخلط الاوراق فيما يتعلق
بما يجري من المفاوضات في الصخيرات او في
اماكن
اخرى نعم الدول الاقليميه التي تدعم
عسكريا وسياسيا احد الطرفين وتدعم الحل
العسكري وكذلك الاطراف الداخليه التي تؤمن
بالحل العسكري هي قادره على قلب على على
على خلط الاوراق وعد وتعطيل المسار نحو
نحو حل سياسي وحل نحو حل ديمقراطي اظن ان
الحل من اجل تجاوز هذا هذه الاطراف التي
تحاول خلط الاوراق هو فك الارتباط يجب ان
تفك الارتباط الاطراف التي هي موجوده سواء
في برلمان طبرق او التي هي موجوده في
المؤتمر الوطني العام في فجر ليبيا او في
عمليه الكرامه واقصد خصوصا هنا البرلمان
والمؤتمر اي اطراف تؤمن بمبادئ وثوره 17
فبراير يجب عليها ان تفك الارتباط مع كل
الاطراف التي تحاول عرقله الحل السياسي
واقصد هنا مثلا يجب على برلمانيين طبرق ان
يفكوا ان يفكوا الارتباط مع الجهات
والجهات
والشخصيات الذين هم جزء من النظام القذافي
والذين عادوا الى المشهد السياسي يجب ان
يفكوا الارتباط مع جماعه حفتر لان حفتر لا
يؤمن ديمقراط يؤمن هو بدوله على شاكله
دوله القذافي وكذلك على جماعه فجر ليبيا
ان يفك الارتباط مع اي اطراف لا تؤمن
بالدوله المدنيه اشكرك وت معنا من باريس
صلاح القادري الباحث السياسي الجزائري
المختص في قضايا العالم العربي والاسلامي
كما اشكر ضيفي من واشنطن نبيل ميخائيل
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه جورج
واشنطن وكذلك ضيفي من طرابلس عصام الزبير
وهو المحلل السياسي الذي كان ضيفنا من
طرابلس
الليبيا بذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ن